ciao amici allora solo non nella mia
cameretta sempre a torino sono però non
nella mia cameretta oggi
ok oggi un mio amico mi ha prestato
d'ufficio che mi stanno fuori superando
la camera quindi oggi sono qua e volevo
fare un video un po diverso dal solito
volevo fare sempre will you preste
bastano quindi quella roba lì che devi
decidere se una cosa da presti o meno il
problema è che gli serve compagni di
oggi per farlo è né uno yogi bear che
non non mai importato sul mio canale
quindi oggi vorrei introdurre i ragazzi
di questo parlando quindi chroniques
roig ha un bel cross
va bè ragazzi oggi sfuggono il garim
dilata stiamo per recare il video suo
lui ma non ha quindi ci stiamo e i pali
che ci scrivono in realtà stavo cercando
di far scaldare carini prima di
registrare il suo video in realtà è
perché devo scaldarmi anche io però non
dirlo non è l'unico non sempre sa che
cos'è meglio imprese battente si è
un'attrice di feste o psicologico più
molto più rigidi lotta di quello che
pensi sito che ti metti un pulsante
rosso e ti mette due opzioni la prima è
positiva la seconda è negativa
mi ispiro un pò come una capra procede
cerca di capire quello che dalle
immagini che siano stati consegnati noi
risposto epilazione positiva e se
laccetti però c'è anche un'opzione
negativo quindi a quel punto che ci
disse parlano lascia stare la situazione
in italiano fatta veramente l'agi lo
trova bene qui gli oppressi il tasto ha
trattato anche fitto lavori umili
oppressi il tasto benvenuti 3 in questo
caso le dragon ball diventano leale
reali ma non puoi mai esprimere il
desiderio di migliorarsi però potrei
scegliere qualsiasi altra cosa sarei
qualsiasi altra cosa però migliorarti
molto generico e nel senso se io volessi
so di infiniti potrei farlo puoi
migliorare e migliorarsi secondo noi i
soldi non rendono una persona migliore
non è mio è una bugia incredibile e
quindi vuol dire che dovremo drago per
il bene dell'umanità siccome spazio per
le batterie del male a me non lo faremo
next mi piace già 16 partito diventate
grande giocatore del suo sport preferito
imbattibile guadagni solo 25mila dollari
all'anno a 16 di giocare
professionalmente sebbene tu possa
ancora avere un'altra occupazione
quindi la cosa sarebbe lo fai per la
passione o lo fai per i soldi non lo
farò
assolutamente no quel demone puoi solo
la chitarra meglio di van allen
ogni volta che sono una canzone qualcuno
a ferrara la fede qualcuno già la peste
nera come fai sempre un po generico
forno che va bene se non va bene perché
se è meno del 5 per cento della
popolazione ma chi se ne frega
settanta non è così contagiosa sempre
stato perché se io non mai sono maturati
tra anche io non sono capace quindi
meglio di male all'improvviso si firmate
risolutamente sempre della peste nera va
benissimo se non a qualcuno l'aveva
fatto veramente diventi un programmatore
di giochi di ruolo molto bello
non puoi creare il tuo gioco sono i
giochi che altre persone piccolo di fare
quindi un di software
ciao possiamo metterla sì sì e non lo so
e mi sembra un po stupido più che altro
perché controproducente però se dipende
se l'obiettivo di questo gioco diventare
ricchi in generale o in italia una
risposta per diventare ricchi si profile
esco ho finalmente una domanda che fa
per noi altrimenti infinitamente
infinitamente ricco globalmente famoso e
immortale certamente meglio di fede il
90 per cento della popolazione terrestre
muore improvvisamente del fantasma si
fermi e che l'auto del nuir mentre
qualcuno perché non solo diventi ricco e
quindi se il più figo di tutti proprio
la popolazione diventa un decimo quindi
sei ancora più figo perché tra giochi
con veramente poche persone sono figli e
fanta spero se colleghiamo anche quello
di primo a suonare la chitarra da dio
linea che ora per quel 10 per cento
forse il codice per quello che sei fra
notano chi ha aggiunto azioni veloci
assolutamente sì sto dicendo alla fine
si installa gente che è colpa nostra noi
che le trasportarti ora sei un ragazzo
grasso o una ragazza grassa se sei un
ragazzo non ho capito cioè quelli che
puoi teletrasportare mal diventi casso e
isaac praticamente veramente una pillola
questo io penso che se diventassi grasso
del sindh romanzo diventa normale che
dice ma che lo slap sì e io no però io
mi hanno detto come noto no però perché
le trasportarmi dai anche perché di
vento grasso non posso più spostarmi coi
mezzi pubblici e di teletrasporto primi
murray arrabbiatissimo perché quando
parliamo insieme finisce 6 3 dal
discorso dei grassi entro il mese molti
tutto tutto sempre ok altri prima di di
legge alla vorrei dire ma secondo te
perchè c'è come gli è venuta in mente
una cosa del genere accetta tutte le
capisco lo sterminio della popolazione
ma la negatività di questa domanda come
le è venuta in mente è un fastidio ma
commercio è proprio quella cosa lì ma se
le persone che tutto è chiaro non devi
portare un pallone usato in tasca però
si annulla la cosa che sei solo perché
nessuno chiamerebbe con un panno
limitata però ti dà l'opportunità usato
per noi in un associato
se quindi mi fa piacere che noi non
abbiamo nessun dubbio sullo
straordinario il 90 per cento come
russell e pannolini sul futuro lino
potete capire questo caso forse no se no
però tutte le persone che amano tutte si
è cercato di a lavorare la casa era
assolutamente a brain una ferrari per il
suo ventunesimo compleanno tu sei già fu
moria di brutto anche io né tratta
quindi cosa sto parlando
non puoi guidarlo quindi sempre io sì
perché la prima volta che fortuna ospite
che non al tridente incredibile ma
perché ci ho 17 anni ancora non posso
quindi va bè sì tanto la lega se
immortale tutti tornati a muoiono di
vecchiaia dia sempre la sua vita cosa
quindi mentre di forza è vero c'è
l'immortale mi basta perché il resto è
normale che se quindi si basa che non
facciamo né con il uomo di centenario
che lui fa quella questa è la storia del
bicentenario poi ci sono le palle break
che ha permesso la malinconia il tuo
video registro malissimo per memorizzare
etica e qualsiasi cosa tu scelga senza
sforzo puoi dedicare solo tre volte al
mese non importa quanto tu voglia andare
bene non può e rumore che esplode marco
infatti mi deve dire cosa succede
defecando solo tre volte al mese sto
malissimo per due settimane è nata la
cosa di memorizzare le robe iniziativa
di cola adesso mister nominale in lega
mi riferì mi va bene no tanto c'è
facebook e chi se ne frega anni ha posto
sorpassano pieni
potevi il ragazzo la ragazza dei sogni
sono gay quindi cosa lotti anni a fare a
meno che non sia già che urla e poi
smorzarsi ma non si può quindi non credo
si fanno ma non è troppo è troppo
abbiamo contrario no peccato per tutti
quanti pensano tutto sia stupendo vi
dice ma io ho sognato di vedere germania
quando si sono sono di vista musico
bellissimo ma che ti guardo vedo lei ma
bellissimo assolutamente anzi penso che
per gli altri se spendo sia vedere
proprio gemmate arte a dire secondo me
in quanto è in forza alle fiere devi
andare ad hogwarts quindi ottimo però
poi lavorare solo con gaza comunque no
in realtà non
no possono il gatto non lo so però non
lo farei mai
non so perché nelle stime azioni lunga
zero o riceve 10 milioni di dollari
spendere i soliti farà fisicamente ma le
piu spendi chi tifa massa interessante
potrebbe se sì sicuramente
dipende sempre quanto cenni si spezza
amati da ogni volta che vado a prelevare
al bancomat progetto bellissimo spendere
soldi mi fa male con canone dei montesi
è così quindi appennino ligure ancora
peggio ottieni una ps 4 è una copia
gratuita di gta 5 per giocarci fa madre
di venere a calci all'inguine 15 volte
che non a playstation 4 così sia silvio
di olivo trovare un calcio all'inguine
in soldi niente a 15 ma poi di fila
un'offerta mese di fila e quella stiamo
troppo alla terza donna sentita la
scommessa dello schiaffo di donne
firmate da qui all'eternità quindi si
vota io no io mi rendono non credo valga
la pena gta 5 sopra per le ragazze vale
qualcosa da una messa domanda quindi
probabile no però grazie della proposta
di venti migliori al mondo di vivere
nella cantina delle nonne poiché le
lunghe le nonne più norme basta che puoi
allenarti a fare il dj in cantina sì
perché se diventi il miglior dice nel
mondo giri un sacco quindi in cantina ci
vai solo a natale per festeggiare coi
parenti filati che così quindi ok
ragazzi io ringrazio karin per aver
partecipato a questo video brevissimo ci
siamo riscaldati e ci siamo subito che
sarà già uscito quindi però lasciato di
petizioni e grazie
e noi ci vediamo il prossimo video se
dovessi iscrivetevi però mi manca
telecom ha detto quindi chiediamo quella
tassa le leggi metto la mano sarà la
tassa sul suo dare una mano
zuma solo perché mentre
[Musica]